Andrew Tate is a legend I mean no no
wait no Andrew Tate so Andrew Tate is in
prison for 30 days yes on what
not sex trafficking that's what everyone
thought at first they thought it was sex
trafficking organized crime allegations
correct connection to what the mafia
yeah is that it organized crime so yeah
I guess you would believe Mafia okay but
there's a few allegations they've been
investigating since his last arrest in
April allegedly he one of his women that
was making like fifty thousand fifty
five thousand a month on the cams that
he was forced to work said she didn't
make a dollar off of it so that's sex
slavery I assume she wasn't a top earner
fit though measly 55
000 a month bro come on that's a 700k a
year okay
so also there was four people arrested
Andrew Tristan Tate and then two other
Romanian women apparently and they said
one of the suspects they didn't say who
but uh I think raped a Woman twice using
violence and then psychological
uh abuse or something like that I don't
necessarily that is the obligations
violence seems like the more pressing
yeah I mean and are they saying one of
the two people they've detained is
accused of doing that one another
so it could be the women which I doubt
or Andrew or Tristan yeah right these
are the allegations these are the
allegations okay okay this is big yeah
this is I thought I'd write a thumb put
them in jail that's what everybody
thought because the timing was dubious
that's what I believed because he was
talking that [ __ ] to Greta and then they
said that they used the pizza boxes yeah
in his retaliation video to prove that
he was in town and then they arrested
him apparently that's [ __ ] yeah
apparently that's not true okay which is
one of those things that when you hear
about it first you're like whoa that's
so crazy and then after you sing about
it would have been so funny yeah there's
no way they're like watching his dreams
like we got him yeah like they just
couldn't see his passport like when he
got in the country and they're like yeah
he's here or just drive up to the castle
and see if he's there yeah right you
just knock on the door and be like hey
is Andrew here yeah there's got to be
other ways for the government to know if
you're in the country other than like
you ordering like pepperoni pizzas 100
okay
um so what do you think sunburn thing
was funny as [ __ ] though what the I we
just never seen Andrew Tate take an L
yeah and then to take it from my
grandfather not a good look good well I
don't even know why he picked that fight
isn't that like uh a pretty bad chess
move his dad would be disappointed but I
feel like people take shots at her all
the time but he like went specifically
at her about global warming and then
it's like dude you're picking a fight
with a teenage girl if you win what do
you get you dunk on her is everybody
going to celebrate or if she dunks on
you is the whole world's gonna be like
this is amazing you know I mean it was a
stupid move and I really think that was
the first time we saw him fall and then
that made the jail thing more like yeah
dude he's it's ready it's I feel like
somehow we're more are like okay with it
yeah because we saw him take that blow
yeah I mean I yeah I love trying to dunk
on Greta thoughts
the whole point of this podcast
where did you go on vacation where did
you go son you tweeted at her or you
tweeted out you wanted a bunch of people
and then thundberg was a part of it and
you made fun of a thousand I made it I
made a tweet to Greta like the day
before he did
maybe she doesn't think you have small
dick energy maybe she thinks you have
big dick energy that's also possible you
know it is what it is I don't know I did
something I forget maybe it was a tweet
maybe it's something oh yeah I saw
somebody like save the [ __ ] I saw
somebody save oh no the guy planted the
most trees ever it was like some
Canadian kid planted 23 000 trees in a
day oh yeah yeah we got actually a lot
of tweets about Greta oh yeah an insane
amount now that I'm looking at it yeah
anyway
um
listen I love it I love it she didn't
give you the energy though why do you
think that is she don't want the smoke
she knows what time it is she doesn't
want the smoke that's a greenhouse gas
yeah I mean that's true that's right
that's good right there I see that